Rose joins us now from our central
London studio congratulations for your
award tonight it's been quite a a twelve
months for you hasn't it it's been quite
a twelve months that that is an
understatement yes what did you feel
about collecting this award the
inspiration or the first time it's been
awarded to a woman
I felt getting the award was really an
amazing declaration on behalf of those
who've had their voices silenced and I
think I'm just there as a representative
for others who've been silenced and
that's what I do my work for and I'm
immensely proud do you feel despite all
that that has been laid bare in the
media over the last 12 months that there
are still people who are being silenced
in the media I absolutely believes there
are I you know I wrote a book called
brave and it's not a Hollywood towel but
if I wanted to I could have destroyed
the known universe I just didn't want to
write a tell-all it's for other people
to say but there are still complicity
machines there's still things being
hidden but it's all you know this is
progress not perfection and and we're
starting to talk it's a great thing do
you regret coming out and speaking out
or or is it something that you're really
glad you've done it's a really mixed bag
you know there are moments of course
that I have you know what have I done
and then most moments though honestly it
was a date with justice that was really
long overdue for me and many others and
I said about this plan about 20 years
ago after it happened to me I did swear
that I would see my day of reckoning and
hopefully for so many others so in terms
of the others that you say are still
there you haven't spoken out would you
urge them to speak out - or or would you
urge some caution I would urge both you
know I think we have to look at due
process but also it's important for
people to not protect others I mean we
saw it with the priests abuse scandals
we see it in Hollywood we see it in
media we see it in politics and we could
probably see it at our local McDonald's
do you know what I mean it's it's all of
these things that are together and I
think when people get more brave and
when people see others coming forward
and not
even though you know they did their best
to do a lot of really bad things to me
and I'm sure they wouldn't have minded
if I passed away but I fought and I
fight to keep living and I fight for
others and I think that others need to
fight for others as well your book brave
that you've mentioned it's been
described as being both a memoir and a
manifesto have you written it for did
you write it for yourself or have you
got someone in mind when you were
writing it that's a great question I
wrote it for the world
I wrote it to unwire people's thoughts I
compare the cult I grew up in so the
cult of Hollywood and how it affects
your mind in ways you might not be aware
of and that's wrapped up in an
autobiography and I really I wrote it
for myself I suppose that I you know it
benefited me in that I worked through a
lot of things like processed a lot of
emotions and it was very hard but over
the course of time I realized you know
my father I watched him as a leader in
this cult on you know why are people's
minds and I kind of know how to unwire
them and that it's it's really in my
form of public service we've talked a
little bit about about Harvey Weinstein
Abbey you've reached a settlement with
him is it something that you're content
with I suppose is the best way of
phrasing it well that was about 21 years
ago or 20 years ago that I requested
money because my intention as a young
woman I thought $100,000 was a lot of
money I wanted to buy a billboard that
said Harvey Weinstein is a rapist and
surprisingly they did not let me buy the
billboard the Outdoor company but it was
always my intention I never signed an
NDA I refused so that's why I was always
being targeted by him for the last 20
years in both media and in the industry
you know a heavy heavy black listing
that I somehow managed to survive and
get a job on a TV show so I could fight
my way through it one of the benefits of
being on that TV shows that was popular
all over the world and so I knew when it
came time to strike that it would be
newsworthy you'd be predators being that
the force behind the me2 movement though
that we talked about in it it it it grew
very very quickly didn't it we were you
surprised by how quickly it was picked
up on across the world
I am so immensely proud of that you know
I think
- what Tirana Berk started was amazing
with a hashtag that just gives us a way
to actually communicate about something
that happened to us it's not like
there's a bunch of women with pitchforks
running after you know executives me too
is fundamentally at its heart just about
a shared experience in a way for people
that have survived this and there's an
awful lot of us men and women who
survive this to have a way to talk to
each other about it you know and I am
immensely proud of how far it spread and
and it just needs to be given time to
breathe you know what I mean we've never
been here before in society I wanted to
change the cultural landscape and the
cultural conversation and so I'm really
glad that we're all having this very
adult conversation that needed to be had
well you can send that it's being
devalued sometimes that there have been
some people who've used it and they've
you know for perhaps that you know
somebody at work inappropriately asking
them out for a date or something
something they feel is inappropriate but
when you compare it to your experience
or the experience of a lot of women
who've been physically sexually and
mentally abused do you feel that that
there's a danger that it devalues
perhaps some of the worst excesses I
think it's again it's about having a
collective conversation and setting
boundaries and not knee-jerk reactions
but understanding you know we all know
the difference we're we're adults we
know the difference you know when you're
younger you don't necessarily not offend
for yourself and it doesn't mean that as
an adult you don't get attacked my point
is just that that conversation about
someone asking not to dinner which I
don't think you know I hope that doesn't
really happen but if someone is offended
by that then they can say that and they
can set boundaries right then and there
there's also of course Asia Argento and
and she you know was a friend of yours
and was also very part of the meteor
campaign there's been this whole story
about her and Jimmy Bennett now we
you're not going to go into who's right
or who's wrong and who says what and
that but has that in it anyway sullied
the the me2 movement do you think you
know the me2 movement again it's just
about a shared experience so I don't
think there's anything that anybody can
do to take that away I have so many
people that stopped me on the street or
send me messages on insta
you know and they talked to me about
it's the first time they've ever told
anybody and there's a lot of boys and
men in that group I include and I don't
think so you know I think it's a
personal setback and a setback for it's
it's shocking and dismaying but I think
you know this is a strong movement and
this is a way for women and and other
victims to stand up and be counted and I
don't think that can be taken away now
do you we surprised at all by the level
of vitriol that you presumably had been
at the receiving end of since since this
came up the be level of anger there is
against women who stand up and speak out
I was very aware before I spoke because
I helped set the articles up the New
York Times and I'm the first one to go
on the record I went on the record of
NBC even though they sat on it for many
months I knew it was going to be a huge
backlash and as somebody who was sold
and marketed for years as a sex symbol
I'm very aware of the vitriol out there
and I wasn't surprised
i-i-i still think these people can be
better humans would you encourage your
daughter to go into the same industry
that you've been in all these years now
we now know what you know about it
absolutely not you wouldn't know even
even being brave and standing up for
herself and and knowing what you know
maybe now I was discovered so I have a
different relationship with it I never
went there trying to be famous it really
did just happen I was standing on a
street corner and was discovered and two
weeks later was starring in a film so I
never quite had that that Drive of you
know needing Fame or something like that
so I would hope my daughter wouldn't
have that drive but I hope now I've been
hearing from a lot of people that things
are a lot better on sets that people
aren't being screamed at and abused as
much that women in the writing room are
being heard for the first time and I
think there has been a shift and I think
it will continue to grow Hollywood is a
mafia and it operates as such you know
people don't speak out there because
they're the bred to have fear I was you
know bred to be in fear for years
but I knew that my time of strength
would come and the time of reckoning
would come